welcome back everybody welcome back Maya
my next guests DVD cutman
is available from his website please
welcome the very funny Ryan Sickler
everybody writes a clog
Thanks that was electric everybody oh
man you guys got to forgive me I am
still trying to unwind right now I was
driving here tonight and I was sitting
in the middle lane at this stoplight and
I heard these tire starts skidding
behind me and then when I looked up my
rearview it was a dude right behind me
has ever happened to you before right
man my stomach dropped my adrenaline
started pumping I gripped the steering
wheel I was like please let this guy hit
me I need this 16 out of this one maybe
twenty two of the good lawyer
you know whiplash runs in my family
I'm not asking you for much I just want
to be this intersections winning lotto
ticket because I do not do the work
thing well the last real job I had fired
me so fast and I didn't come on national
television tonight to bash the company
so let's just say it rhymes with Disney
usually I can't even get past the
interview process you ever lied so much
on a resume that when he asked you
something you're like it says that my
objective was to own a bakery and you
start panicking saying stuff done he
makes sense you're like that's probably
a cutting pace to hair right there
you know how word is no I don't know
anything about the cupcakes man I'm
gonna need to get that back make some
revisions and nothing gets me angrier
than someone that talks down to me it
makes me feel like I'm less than they
are when I can do their job you know
like that idiot at Costco with the
highlighter I can't stand that guy
always so over-the-top
always so dramatic there's like nine
hundred of you right now there's only
one of me you're rolling up here with a
cart full of stuff right now how am I
supposed to know you just pay for all
that stuff how am I supposed to know
you're not stealing from this company
give me a receipt paperwork you actually
take money each week that I think you
might be the one stealing I can do that
seriously if anyone's looking for a
professional highlighter I can do that
I'm available part-time
part work time you gotta have money to
take the pretty girls out not the ugly
ones they're usually cool just coming
over to kick it if it's a pretty one
need to have a little scratch for them
gals and I love you ladies I could talk
to you all night long
I am so sick of hearing guys say they
don't know how to talk to women anymore
I could talk to you all all night long I
just don't know how to answer your
questions you guys asked some messed-up
questions on purpose you do it on
purpose you ask woman out today you have
no idea what you'll hear I asked this
girl out I was like here's what if maybe
like that dinner sometime do you mean do
you mean as friends no detectives
I thought we get a bite to eat and hit
the crime-lab
maybe solve a couple cases you know
anything about forensics can you
character sketch I forget it friends it
is we'll go ahead and be friends I just
made a new female friend America I'm so
excited to have her on board man I've
heard some had a girl ask me one time if
I've ever had sex with any women for
revenge
what no I've never done that before
I slept with a few for free haircuts
yeah those girls work hard give it up
they work hard man who's got time to
plot and scheme just plug the Clippers
in and let them run loose man I got
things to do go Late Late Show that's my
time I'm Ryan Sickler thank you good
night